stock photos is a national treasure
stock photos need to be preserved at all
cost stock photos has given us some of
the greatest memes of this time stock
photos is a way for us to express
ourselves in emotions we didn't even
know we had so let's go through some of
the greatest stock images of all time
smash like on this video if you are
super into it
grandpa teaches blond children important
life lessons why I like how there's a
story here you know clay let the child
has done some Victor's hand why are all
the kids blonde - it's very weird I of
course know the answer of this this is
the famous Fifi Paula me test that all
Swedish kids that are blond has to go
through in Sweden at the age of 12 this
of course is a man presenting hot dogs
this is how I presented my hot dogs when
I was working in a hot dog stand this is
how you would find me exactly like this
so who directed this yeah exactly I
can't imagine someone directing this
photo shoot
it was unprovoked the photographer just
happened to have his camera sometimes
you never know when the perfect
opportunity of a photo is gonna strike
you just never know excuse me sir what
do you have in that saucepan this oh yes
that's sausages would you like a photo
yes please okay here you go
epic that's just how I imagined it went
down people have different theories of
course people allowed to speculate of
course here's this a woman who spits on
oh I'm not gonna read that out loud how
do you get to do that on that bird I am
so confused
I am Vietnamese I've seen this before in
Vietnam
it's very common but I'm not sure I'm
more confused now what the hell you
can't just drop that people do it before
a pee by it's a pre-fight blessing if I
weird lemmy's woman spits on you I'll
keep that in mind for my inevitable
chaos I pretty pie or Logan vs.
PewDiePie 5 drink-driving taken to a new
level I've seen this I just assumed this
was fake
it's actually DejaVu I have been in this
phase before hey bruh take a sip it
turns back 45 degrees let's ride
oh I bet you can make this exit this in
time hold my beer
what is that quote from the matrix did
you say to avoid the highway the highway
it's suicide
guy reaches through computer screen and
times backwards while a surprise cat
looked off in the distance
thank you for describing the image for
people that are blind but there you go
that's what I'm looking at here and it's
exactly what you think it is and I'm
equally as confused oh god no what is
this I think my photo shops are weird
this is all for mime my my I don't know
where I keep my pails do you know where
I kept my pills Oh son just check my
knees here you go son
oh thanks mom I love the abundance of
Pitney pills if only I had legs I could
actually understand what that felt like
m'lady I've seen this oh that's a stock
image I want that hat loke want that
head not gonna lie that guy looks
straight-up Alf I'll take five nobody
stock photos it's like that office
episode when Will Ferrell screams at the
cake when your salad keeps telling you
jokes I don't know what it is about
salad it's just hilarious
I can I'm back out there
reality buddy eating a salad oh god the
lettuce tastes like nothing
what am i doing hacker stock photos are
the best wow that's incredible
that's really bad that's just not clever
or funny or nothing when it's the fourth
time this week you've forgotten to pull
your pants down yeah if he was just
sitting on it without the toilet paper
in his hand it wouldn't be that weird
I peed through my jeans all the time but
since the answer toilet paper he's
obviously poopy which is really gross
wait you don't pee through your pants
bro what guys check this out check this
guy out he doesn't pee through his pants
Oh cringe oh my god that looks like
jacksepticeye she says Lord tell
that does not look like older fatter
jacksepticeye what in the world and the
septic nests is coming out of his ear
memory loss is more people what Jackie
burger baby burger baby what gender
burger baby is we're waiting to the
birth to reveal it someone stop this man
yeah why what the punk bracelet really
shows how hardcore this guy is someone
stop him please so he proposes I assume
she says no and apparent oh wow okay
this is actually how me and Marshall
proposed she was forced to say yes
basically hell I mean I can't be mad I
do these kind of photo shops but why
would you need a stock image of that
that is my question
I wonder if stock imagery it's like a
lucrative business or not because it
seems so easy to do maybe that's naive
for me to say but I don't know like edit
what is it it's like youtuber PD PI's
quits YouTube to create stock imagery
woman is robbing bakery with a baguette
okay I guess it's a great braid if he
gets shot it will be painting named
sorry
Manning eyepatch pretending to play the
violin with an abacus and a bow tie why
is he layering as clothes like that ah
it's like the details that does it yeah
like this is weird in itself and then
you add all these other stuff Oh Kruger
you caught me keeping a bowl of crackers
in the fridge
what kind of maniac keep your crackers
in the fridge guys this girl keeps
cracker in the fridge
creig cringe what is wrong with you
chocolate lungs in the fridge chocolate
belongs in the fridge chocolate belongs
in the fridge I said it three times now
you have to put all your chocolate in
the fridge like a normal human being
thank you very much oh wow what is what
stop stop stop it up I request a full
stop I have permission from the
government a full stop and is in order
now stop it stop it now stop how many
cameras does your phone have
mine has fine it's got quad-cam on the
bank that's right honored 20 Pro say it
after me under 20 pro four cameras you
want to take the perfect shot the main
camera has 48 megapixel but who's
counting are you too close when you're
alone with all your friends and want to
capture all of them try the wide-angle
lens
16 megapixels super wide angle so you
and all your non-existing friends can be
in the shot want to take really closely
creepy shots on people well now you can
with the macro sensor we can get super
close uncomfortably close and finally
the 8 megapixel telephoto sensor that
has 3 times optical zoom and 30 times
digital zoom
now you can finally see PP and of course
front camera 5 cameras everyone knows
more cameras met their phone for real
beyond er 20 a pro is a super cool phone
I've been using the other phones for a
real long time the new dynamic color
graphic design in glass spec it's
looking very Hecate heck and nice and I
know you're all serious gamers out there
the honor 20 pro it's got pro in it
which will give you the best gaming
experience thank you Anna for sponsoring
this video
ok keep on with video bye bye from an
article about teenagers becoming
radicalized online help me help me come
out of this computer place I'm getting
sucked in they got my left butt cheek
please alligator
attacking businesswomen in office
cubicle it can happen at any given time
it is an issue we're just working on it
why would you need this I feel like if
you're gonna make sock imagery at least
make it something you can eat alright if
I'm running a business what do I want
not that that's not what I want if I was
running a business I would want the
girls eating salad like when would you
use this when would you use this I get
the message and I get what you're saying
but like why would anyone buy their head
it's so specific that's what I mean with
look at they like can't you just make
stock imagery that are actually
useful its stock images like those
mobile phone game ads that are just like
weird an obscure to draw attention and
it actually works like I don't
understand it it's so confusing lemon
with tongue and disembodied Robert
rubber glove okay but Wow
but wow it looks it long Furby that
March they wanted to make I thought I
could justify my sudden need of owning a
long Furby by creating one for a video I
was denied I guess me and my sty should
make one cuz I never heard back from
Willie and Osmond why somebody remade
this remember the cake pillow case what
happened when I sent it to my cousin oh
it's not up yet wait okay do we have
answers we have answers for once there's
a background behind the stock image
Getty Images in 2007 I worked with a
photographer to document a concept piece
of a man me sleeping on a sheet cake it
was a simple visual pun a cake that
looked like a pillow and there's obvious
play on sweet dreams there was no intent
other than creating ambiguous benign
image that we did and releasing it to
the world few years later images from
the shoot were sold to get images as
stock photos then in 2011 one of those
photos appeared as number 13 on the
BuzzFeed list okay 60 completely
unusable stock photos see that's the
thing they're all unusable right now
claimed by online culture as a proper
mean the image constantly reappears I
never seen it before
oh god these are even better you're
proud of something and no one cares this
is so sad how is BuzzFeed still a thing
Jesus Lord why did this just suck out
all the fun from it knowing that
BuzzFeed made a version of it yeah oh my
god what do I do with this why is David
Tennant uncomfortably holding a blobfish
is his child dave intended that's a
mighty fine blobfish
I refuse to believe that blob fishes are
real oh my god how do you get one I
thought they were like a rare or
something
awful hey hard to swallow pills got it
epic we deliver pizza to literally
anywhere hello she would rat would you
like some pizza very well here you go
sir men poking a GPU card with a
soldiering iron isn't there the one with
a web and the hostess soldering iron
with her hand which I think in
retrospect is probably a meme it's
another sock photo
it's another sock but as she holds it
there women can do epicness also
beautiful women can still do epicness
also beautiful webbing oh good old stock
images you never know what you're gonna
get girl so what do you do for a living
me stock photo model girl what type of
stock photos oh you just wait girl I
think you're gonna like what you find
oh my god have bed bear it seems like a
funny YouTube idea you get a bunch of
youtubers you create the each one of
them creates the weirdest stock photos
and the one that gets the most sales
wins another person with a soldiering
iron so many of them are just like super
inappropriate I can't even show them
like this one like come on
wow what it looks so happy about it
let's get real that we all stuck our
peepee through there right let's get
real here we've all done it
just say yes you don't have to say yes
just blink that's what I thought by man
respect that's respect so how did you
ruin your computer again well I was just
answering emails that's literally all I
did oh my god why would you do this why
why hey look it's visage why are they
all so strangely comedic and weird
here's a video like that weird but at
the same time where's the fort night
dance huh no four night dance no up
trust nobody not even yourself you can't
even trust anybody not even yourself
this day this song is so uncomfortable
it's like
they traded bodies or something this
like at full movies like Freaky Friday
but a blobfish and some BC list
celebrity like that could be a really
interesting story I feel like about love
and friendship and hope and stuff like
that oh my lord
is that the thing from Star Wars that's
definitely the thing from Star Wars
isn't it why the knees stop fricking
with the knees dude I'm done with the
knees
no more knees permission to stop I show
it here permission to stop you have to
accept much weighs more a kilogram of
potatoes per kilogram of steer
jacksepticeye still doesn't know the
answer this is so sad you ever just feel
like throwing spaghetti around in the
forest is what me and my I said do on
our weekend in case you're wondering
what we do on our weekend this is what
we do on our weekend hey lady
it I don't think your computer is on my
god she's lasted she's a complete
sociopath she's a complete psychopath I
better go to another house goddamn the
cat is back isn't it I mean fair enough
fair enough if you have to do what you
got to do to make your living you know
check cept the guy when he realized he
had too many potatoes no thank you
I've had enough potatoes for today I've
already had 50,000 oh god I haven't seen
it up close before it's so uncomfortable
it's so horrible they're kind of cute
like blue eyes like legit Oh a trick and
here we'll twist the kid's torso around
for no reason at all okay apparently
banana phone is the pinnacle of stock
imagery comedy they just can't have
enough of banana phones I just I just
love banana phone sisal arias this is
literally me when I started drinking
again all the classic okay so like salad
start out with salad FL is good a great
way I spray kur to get some laughs out
all right they move on to some other
things and oh boy that got really weird
really fast
these are like my weird Photoshop videos
I'm basically looking at other people
making these like at least I have a
reason for it okay at least I have a
purpose I have a purpose right okay
people like you
see something nice please I haven't
heard nice comments oh god it's
examining macaronis oh that's an egg oh
that's an Hank oh that's not how you
hard swallow pills take one of these
three times a day okay sure
all right you know what I think I had
enough I think that goes it's a point
where you think no thanks enough thank
you very much stuff thanks for watching
this video if you enjoyed it smash like
and hit subscribe I upload videos every
single day did you know that every day
every day I upload videos every day
every day every day every day every day
no matter what I get a video up every
day thanks to save and me oh yeah if you
want to support channel check out the
merch and that's it see you tomorrow bye
bye we're all excited about the new game
that's coming out and I can't wait to
play it it starts with a letter P can
you guess what it is here the pie pick
ceiling of course what you thought it
was Pokemon dumbass you stinky brainer
you